[Music]
I think they all they want we're just
here to play ball
it's just a bunch of crack pipes still
fighting the Civil War
well hell would have won that son of a
gun if the corn stocks were held out we
just ran out of ammunition
we're gonna look next time peewee
ain't gonna be a next time Jake in
August of 2020 the world lost a truly
remarkable Talent after a four-year
battle with colon cancer Chadwick
Boseman who broke into the mainstream
with an acclaimed performance is
baseball Legend Jackie Robinson in 42
began the role that would define him
t'challa and black panther and in
Captain America Civil War in 2016 and
went on to play the character in Black
Panther Avengers end game and Avengers
Infinity War
[Music]
he also played Thurgood Marshall and
Marshall and James Brown in Get on Up
Bozeman was just 43 at the time of his
death as we still mourn this Monumental
loss we'd like to celebrate his life and
his memory as we count down the best
Chadwick Boseman movies
[Music]
number 10 draft day
Sunny Weaver Jr is the general manager
of the Cleveland Browns one of pro
football's most important days NFL draft
day is Drawing Near but Sunny is much
more on his mind than just which players
to recruit his lover is pregnant and the
team's owner wants to fire him after
Sunny accepts a deal with Seattle that
Nets him the team's first round pick he
immediately wonders if he's made the
right choice for himself and the Browns
starring Chadwick Boseman Jennifer
Garner Kevin Costner and directed by
Ivan Reitman critics say it's perfectly
Pleasant for sports Buffs and Costner
fans but overall draft day lives down on
its title by relying too heavily on the
sort of by the Numbers storytelling that
only a statistician could love hello
good morning Mr Sunny Weaver Jr show
number one fan vonte Mack Monty how'd
you get this number you gave it to me at
the combo
sorry if I called in that's all right
this look doesn't matter vonte the
giraffe draft doesn't start until late
where are you New York no man they want
me up there Radio City but I wanted to
be here in Virginia with my grams
let's see how she can't make that trip
so
who you picking
fires you I take a lightning quick
middle linebacker who can murder the
gaps in the 3-4 totally agree you got
Reggie Wilson's number down there in
Purdue
you know I really don't find that funny
number nine Get on Up James Brown was
born in extreme poverty in 1933 South
Carolina and survived abandonment abuse
and jail to become one of the most
influential musicians of the 20th
century he joined a gospel group as a
teenager but the Jazz and Blues along
with the chitlin circuit became his
springboard to fame although his backup
musicians came and went Brown retained
the ability to Mesmerize audiences with
his music signature moves and Sexual
Energy starring Chadwick Boseman Nelson
Ellis Dan Aykroyd and directed by Tate
Taylor critics say with an unforgettable
Chadwick Boseman in the starring role
Get on Up offers the Godfather of Soul a
fittingly dynamic homage
gone with outside
hey
I really do
and I appreciate your honesty
can't be easy no saying you got your
grievances yeah you got yourselves to
think about
hell Your Man
I dig it I don't think you uh understand
Mr Brown sir
we know you owe the government back
taxes
your restaurant radio stations your
recording studios labels all different
businesses all kind of cash passing
between them unaccounted for
it's a mess Mr Brown if you want us to
be a part of it we're gonna need our
cash too right now
most of all none of us wants to be fined
for anything
ever again
you know what I'm gonna do
imma think about it
that's all
is that what you say to me
[ __ ] you you better get on out of here
right you ain't gonna make me come by
myself you better get out of here right
now
go get the hell out
number 8 42. in 1946 Branch Ricky
legendary manager of the Brooklyn
Dodgers defies Major League Baseball's
notorious color barrier by signing
Jackie Robinson to the team the heroic
act puts both Ricky and Robinson in the
firing line of the public the press and
other players facing open racism from
all sides Robinson demonstrates true
courage and admirable restraint by not
reacting in kind and lets his undeniable
Talent Silence the Critics for him
starring Chadwick Boseman Harrison Ford
Nicole Bahari and directed by Brian
helgeland critics say 42 is an Earnest
inspirational and respectfully told
biography of an influential American
Sports icon though it might be a little
too safe and old-fashioned for some
Robinson with another big lead off first
he's just as Restless as a cap of the
hot foot
the Flatbush faithful voicing their
approval of Jack as this type of Scrappy
play is exactly what they've grown to
expect of their beloved father
[Music]
seriously
take it
[Music]
the Dodgers with an excellent chance
here as Robertson has practically willed
himself into scoring position
number seven Marshall Young Thurgood
Marshall faces one of his greatest
challenges while working as a lawyer for
the NAACP Marshall travels to
conservative Connecticut when wealthy
socialite Eleanor straubing accuses
black chauffeur Joseph spell of sexual
assault and attempted murder he soon
teams up with Sam Friedman a local
Jewish lawyer who's never handled a
criminal case together the two men build
a defense while contending with racists
and anti-semitic views from those who
deem spell to be guilty starring
Chadwick Boseman Josh gadd Kate Hudson
and directed by Reginald hudlin critics
say Marshall takes an Illuminating
well-acted look at its real-life
subjects early career that also delivers
as an entertainingly old-fashioned
courtroom drama what do you have to say
about today's comments by the NAACP what
comments the press release by Walter
White he says that the spell case will
show the world that a color man cannot
get a fair trial in the United States of
America do you agree Mr Freeman I have
nothing to say what about doing Mr
Marshall
as it have been proven in this courtroom
already
how can a man have a fair trial when
he's denied Council of his choice for
the members of his race are eliminated
from service on his jury when fear and
bias against this race are the central
points of the case against him
Europe right now
forces of tyranny have mobilized behind
the vision of a so-called Master race
here in America our differences aren't
supposed to matter
here we're promised equal protection
under the law nothing complicated about
that
that promise has not been realized not
even close
not in Birmingham Alabama nor in
Oklahoma City Oklahoma and certainly not
here in Bridgeport Connecticut number
six Avengers Infinity War Iron Man Thor
the Hulk and the rest of the Avengers
unite to battle their most powerful
enemy yet the evil Thanos on a mission
to collect all six Infinity Stones
Thanos plans to use the artifacts to
inflict his Twisted will on reality the
fate of the planet and existence itself
has never been more uncertain as
everything The Avengers have fought for
has led up to this moment starring
Chadwick Boseman Robert Downey Jr Chris
Hemsworth and directed by Joe and
Anthony Russo critics say Avengers
Infinity War ably juggles a dizzying
array of MCU heroes in the fight against
their gravest threat yet and the result
is a thrilling emotionally resonant
Blockbuster that mostly realizes its
gargantuan ambitions
some things entered the atmosphere
Hey cap we got a situation here
God I love this place yeah don't start
celebrating yet guys we got more
incoming outside the Dome
[Music]
[Music]
it's too late
we need to destroy the stone now Vision
get your back on the table we would hold
them off
as soon as that Stone's out of his head
you blow it to hell I will Evacuate the
city
engage all defenses
get this man a [ __ ]
number five Captain America Civil War
political pressure mounts to install a
system of accountability when the
actions of the Avengers lead to
Collateral Damage the new status quo
deeply divides members of the team
Captain America believes superheroes
should remain free to defend Humanity
without government interference now Iron
Man sharply disagrees and supports
oversight as the debate escalates into
an all-out Feud Black Widow and Hawkeye
must pick a side starring Chadwick
Boseman Chris Evans Robert Downey Jr and
directed by Anthony and Joe Russo
critics say Captain America Civil War
begins the next wave of Marvel movies
with an action-packed superhero
Blockbuster boasting a decidedly
non-cartoonish plot and the courage to
explore thought-provoking themes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
Southwest rooftop Who the hell's the
other guy about to find out
[Music]
Sam got him
[Music]
thank you
number four the five Bloods four
African-American vets battle the forces
of man in nature when they returned to
Vietnam seeking the remains of their
fallen squad leader and the gold Fortune
he helped them hide starring Chadwick
Boseman Delroy Lindo Jonathan majors and
directed by Spike Lee critics say Fierce
energy and ambition course through the
five Bloods coming together to feel one
of Spike Lee's most urgent and impactful
films
everybody all right yeah good right here
well it's about money
money is about one
every time I walk out my front door
she costs Patrol in my neighborhood like
it's some kind of police said I can feel
just how much I ain't worth
give us something to believe in
the direction a purpose
he taught us about black history when it
wasn't really popular back then
schooled us about drinking that
anti-comic Kool-Aid they were selling
he was our Malcolm and Al Martin
no I'm not a way of keeping us from
going off we were no Tom
he was a bad mother shut your mouth
number three Avengers end game a drift
in space with no food or water Tony
Stark sends a message to Pepper Potts as
his oxygen supply starts to dwindle
meanwhile the remaining Avengers Thor
Black Widow Captain America and Bruce
Banner must figure out a way to bring
back their vanquished allies for an epic
showdown with Thanos the evil demigod
who decimated the planet and the
universe starring Chadwick Boseman
Robert Downey Jr Chris Evans and
directed by Anthony and Joe Russo
critics say exciting entertaining and
emotionally impactful Avengers end game
does whatever it takes to deliver a
satisfying finale to Marvel's epic
Infinity Saga
thank you
Captain Sam can you hear me
on your left
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
keep going back
[Music]
[Music]
number two MA rainey's black bottom
tensions and temperatures rise over the
course of an afternoon recording session
in 1920 Chicago as a band of musicians
await Trail blazing performer the
legendary mother of the Blues Ma Rainey
late to the session The Fearless fiery
ma engages in a battle of wills with her
white manager and producer over control
of her music as the band waits in the
Studio's claustrophobic rehearsal room
ambitious cornet player Levy who has an
eye for Ma's girlfriend and is
determined to stake his own claim on the
music industry Spurs his fellow
musicians into an eruption of stories
revealing truths that will forever
change the course of their lives
starring Viola Davis Chadwick Boseman
Glenn Turman and directed by George C
wolf critics say framed by a pair of
Powerhouse performances ma rainey's
black bottom pays affectionate tribute
to a blues Legend and Black Culture at
large what is you I don't see your name
unless I just play the piece whatever
they want I don't criticize other
people's music I like you color I got
if my daddy had a note I was going to
turn out like this he would have named
me Gabriel oh
I'm gonna give me a band and make me
some records I didn't get Mr Man some of
my songs I wrote and he said he's gonna
let me record them when I get my band
together I just got to finish the last
part of this song I know how to play
real music not this old jug man I got
stopped oh everybody got Style Style
ain't nothing but keeping the same idea
from beginning to end everybody got it
everybody can't play like I do everybody
can't have their own band well until you
get your own bam you can play what you
want you just play the piece and stop
complaining I told you when you came on
here this ain't none of them hot bands
this is an accompaniment band you play
Mars music when you're here I got sense
enough to know that hell I can look at
y'all and see what kind of band it is I
can look at Toledo and see what kind of
band it is oh no hey Toledo ain't saying
nothing to you don't get Toledo started
now unless you all gonna rehearse the
music or ain't you how many times you
didn't play them songs what you got to
rehearse for this is a recording session
I want to get it right the first time
and get on out of here man
and finally number one black panther
after the death of his father t'challa
returns home to the African nation of
wakanda to take his rightful place as
king when a powerful enemy suddenly
reappears t'challa's medal is King and
his black panther gets tested when he's
drawn into a conflict that puts the fate
of wakanda and the entire world at risk
faced with treachery and danger the
young king must rally his allies and
release the full power of black panther
to defeat his foes and secure the safety
of his people starring Chadwick Boseman
Michael B Jordan Lupita Nyong'o and
directed by Ryan coogler critics say
black panther elevates superhero Cinema
to thrilling New Heights while telling
one of the mcu's most absorbing stories
and introducing some of its most fully
realized characters
foreign
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
everyone
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]